in ordnung einberufen und nach 21 absatz
3 unserer geschäftsordnung für die
genehmigung bleiben wenn da beschluss
erforderlich
in der fraktion allen vereinbart worden
die noch zu bestiegene tagesordnung und
die in der zusatzpunkt die liste
aufgeführten punkte zu erweitern
von der frist für den beginn der
beratungen soll soweit erforderlich
abgewichen werden nach der fragestunde
soll auf verlangen der fraktion bündnis
90 die grünen eine aktuelle stunde zum
thema arbeitsbedingungen in der
fleischindustrie stattfinden
der tagesordnungspunkt 3 sich soll
abgesetzt und an dessen stelle soll der
anderer corona hilfen für die
reisewirtschaft aufgerufen werden
und damit kommen wir zur feststellung
der tagesordnungen der 159 10 160 161
sitzung mit den genannten änderungen und
ergänzungen wer stimmt dafür bestimmt
dagegen enthält sich dann ist die
tagesordnung gegen die stimmen der afc
mit den stimmen des übrigen hauses so
bis 19 uhr werden tagesordnungspunkt
eins mit fragen der bundesregierung die
bundesregierung hat mitgeteilt dass
sollte die bundeskanzlerin frau dr
zur verfügung steht bundeskanzlerin wenn
sie mögen haben sie das wort für ihre
einleitenden ausführungen
ja herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ich freue mich dass wir heute
die ursprünglich schon für ende märz
geplante regierungsbefragung wird mir
nachholen können ich hatte ja bereits
vor gut drei wochen am 23
april die gelegenheit ihnen in einer
regierungserklärung meinen und unseren
kurs in dieser pandemie aufzuzeigen
in der panini und mit dem virus leben
wir immer noch und das wird auch für
längere zeit so bleiben denn die
grundlegenden fakten haben sich ja nicht
geändert auch wenn einzelne
forschungsansätze hoffnung machen noch
gibt es keine medikamente und keinen
impfstoff gegen das virus coruna ist und
bleibt also eine gefahr für jede und
jeden von uns eine corona infektion kann
in vielen fällen ganz harmlos verlaufen
sie kann aber auch zu schweren schäden
bis zum tod führen und ich denke an all
die menschen die wir an dieses virus
verloren haben und ich denke an ihre
familien das sind die unveränderten
fakten aber wir stehen natürlich nicht
still in dieser pandemie in den drei
wochen seit meiner regierungserklärung
ist einiges geschehen haben wir einiges
geschafft dass uns mut machen kann
wir waren uns von anfang an einig
stoppen können wir die ausbreitung des
virus derzeit nicht aber sie so weit wie
möglich verlangsamen das können und das
müssen wir und das ist ja auch unser
gemeinsames ziel wir können sagen dass
uns in den vergangenen wochen und
monaten in einer gemeinsam enormen
anstrengung gelungen ist dieses ziel zu
erreichen oder ihm näher zu kommen
es ist gelungen weil wir alle bürger
wirtschaft start in einer schweren zeit
und unter schweren einschränkungen
zusammengehalten haben die zahlen der
neuinfektionen die das
robert-koch-institut uns täglich meldet
die liegen jetzt in einem bereich mit
dem unser gesundheitssystem
zurechtkommen kann und es ist wieder
einigermaßen möglich infektionsketten
nachzuverfolgen und durch tests und
quarantänemaßnahmen diese ketten dann
auch zu durchbrechen
die derzeit entwickelte tracing app wird
diese nachverfolgung
hoffentlich bald zusätzlich verbessern
wir haben die letzten wochen genutzt um
unser gesundheitssystem an vielen
stellen auch zu stärken
ich habe großen respekt vor der leistung
der länder und kommunen danke auch den
deutschen bundestag dass mit hilfe des
bundes kapazitäten vor allen dingen für
intensivbetten erhöht werden konnten
und ich sehe die fabelhaften leistungen
die im öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst in
den gesundheitsämtern täglich erbracht
werden und ich bin auch froh dass wir
dort sowohl durch die länder als auch
den durch den bund unterstützung geben
konnten dann das sind genau die orte an
denen die infektionsketten nachvollzogen
werden müssen und davon hängt so vieles
ab uns ist die internationale
zusammenarbeit gegen das virus
herausragend richtig im kreis der
europäischen union unter den g7 staaten
und den g20 ländern
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir
können froh sein dass wir diese letzten
wochen alle zusammen so gemeistert haben
ich sehe darin aber auch eine
verpflichtung die verpflichtung das
gemeinsam erreichte jetzt nicht zu
gefährden
wir haben noch nicht seit märz alle
vorher undenkbaren einschränkungen in
unserem leben in unserem arbeiten und
wirtschaften auch zeitweilige
einschränkungen unserer rechte auf uns
genommen um jetzt weil wir die vorsicht
ablegen einen rückfall zu riskieren
es wäre doch deprimierend wenn wir weil
wir zu schnell zu viel wollen wieder zu
einschränkungen zurückkehren müssten die
wir alle hinter uns lassen wollen
lassen sie uns also mutig und wachsam
sein
lassen sie uns schrittweise das
öffentliche und wirtschaftliche leben
wieder öffnen und dabei die entwicklung
der pandemie immer im blick haben und
vor allem lassen sie uns an
arbeitsplätze in schulen in cafés und
die sportvereine zurückkehren und dabei
die neuen grundregeln weiter beachten
mindestabstand halten händewaschen
respekt vor dem schutzbedürfnis auch
unserer mitmenschen
ich bin jetzt überzeugt denn der
konsequent bleiben und so ein rückfall
verhindern haben wir alle mehr davon
denn dann ist auch in der nächsten phase
der pandemie beides möglich
der schutz der gesundheit der menschen
und ein vorgehen dass unsere wirtschaft
so schnell wie möglich wieder aufholen
lässt und damals zu viel wie möglich
arbeitsplätze sichert und ein
gesellschaftliches leben an dem wir
freude haben können
herzlichen dank danke sehr die erste
frage stellte kollege diego gruppe f d
sehr geehrte frau bundeskanzlerin sie
haben jetzt auf die panel menschen
probleme sind sie eingegangen sich
natürlich auf die wirtschaftlichen
folgen was dieses land betrifft
überhaupt nie eingegangen dessen meine
frage oder bzw
auch erst mal meinen einleitung dazu
ihre corona politik auch die krone
politik der bundesregierung vernichtet
aktuell in deutschland über zwei
millionen menschen ihre existenzen wir
haben über zehn millionen kurzarbeiter
die rücklagen der sozialkassen schmelzen
dahin man geht von 14 milliarden bis
ende des jahres aus wir haben über
300.000 mehr arbeitslose als im vormonat
das bruttoinlandsprodukt zum 6 1 6 3
prozent zusammengebrochen pro woche
kostet uns dieser lockdown 42 milliarden
euro die größte rezession der
nachkriegsgeschichte zu titeln einige
zeitungen ist meine fragen wo ist
eigentlich und iris und auch der
bundesregierung ihr finanzierungskonzept
für nach dieser krise und können sie
hier und heute auch ausschließen dass
der bürger durch erhöhte abgaben und
steuern
diese kosten natürlich übernehmen muss
und auch bezahlen muss diese pandemie
altert in einer wirtschaftlich und auch
fast die haushaltspolitik und die
situation der sozialversicherung
anbelangt guten situation erfasst hat
das heißt wir konnten sehr viele
sicherungsmaßnahmen durchsetzen bin auch
sehr dankbar dass die mehrheit dieses
parlaments das ja auch getan hat durch
die abstimmung und dass menschen in
kurzarbeit sind zeigt dass wir natürlich
wirtschaftliche folgen haben dieser
pandemie aber es zeigt dass wir die
menschen nicht ins nicht entlassen
mussten sondern dass wir helfen können
und dass wir rücken bauen können und das
wird auch weiter unser ziel sein
und ich glaube wenn wir die dinge gut
miteinander vereinbaren dann können wir
alle nicht voraussehen wann wir einen
impfstoff haben waren wir ein medikament
haben aber wir haben die chance es gut
zu bewältigen aber ich sage nicht dass
es niemand etwas merken wird
wir werden alles daran setzen dass
möglichst viele bürgerinnen und bürger
schnell in an ihren arbeitsplatz
zurückkehren können aber ebenso dass es
verantwortbar ist also auf die konkrete
frage ob die steuererhöhungen und
abgabenerhöhungen jetzt im prinzip in
folge der der kosten noch erfolgen von
ihnen habe ich jetzt keine antwort
bekommen dass die nachfrage dazu ob das
ist auch geplant ist in welcher form
natürlich sind existenzen vernichtet
worden was sagen sie dem gastronomen dem
besitzer im prinzip der seine sein
geschäft aufgeben musste der konkurs
gehen musste denn der ist ja von
staatlichen hilfen weitestgehend
ausgenommen worden
nein das ist ja nicht das wissen sie ja
auch es gibt liquiditätshilfen es gibt
die kurzarbeit für die menschen und wenn
jetzt die restaurants wieder aufmachen
dann wird es auch eine
mehrwertsteuersenkung geben und wir
werden natürlich angepasst immer auch
wieder schauen wo müssen wir noch helfen
wir haben nie gesagt dass wir damit
schon am absoluten ende sind wir wenn
auch etwas tun zur stimulierung der
wirtschaft
und ich kann ihnen nur sagen stand heute
sind keinerlei erhöhung von abgaben und
steuern geplant
dann kann das gehört ja zur politik dazu
dass wir zum jetzigen zeitpunkt immer
antworten sonst werden wir ja zukunft
vorhersehen und das maße ich mir nicht
an die nächste frage gestellt der
kollege rainer spiering spd
bundeskanzlerin
der spiegel berichtet ausführlich über
die zustände bei den song arbeitskräften
meiner eigener landkreis ist stark
betroffen
es herrscht partiell unübersichtliche
datenlage sehr geehrte frau
bundeskanzlerin sowohl war den saison
arbeitskräften in der landwirtschaft als
auch die werksarbeiter in der
fleischindustrie
aber die beschäftigen seit jahren unter
unzumutbaren zuständen enge
platzverhältnisse und mangelnde hygiene
haben inzwischen 200 vielzahl von corona
infizierten gefühl
welche konkreten maßnahmen plant die
bundesregierung zusammen mit den
bundesländern damit die missstände
schnellstmöglich beseitigt werden
stimmen sie mit der spd fraktion überein
dass wir eine grundlegende reform dieser
arbeitsbereiche benötigen um
wettbewerbsfähige arbeitsplätze zu
erhalten die gesundheits schutz fairer
löhne und soziale mindeststandards
gewährleisten also die bundesregierung
hat ja bezüglich der saisonarbeitskräfte
ein konzept verabschiedet das auch mit
dem robert-koch-institut abgestimmt ist
und dass den arbeitgebern in der
landwirtschaft sehr viel stärkere
auflagen auferlegt als das früheren
jahren auch der fall war
angepasst natürlich sowohl an den
arbeitsschutz im allgemeinen als auch an
denen in der pandemie
wir haben jetzt über die situation in
der fleischindustrie nochmal
erschreckende nachrichten bekommen sie
werden ja gleich einer aktuellen stunde
darüber auch debattieren
die bundesregierung beabsichtigt auch
hierzu notwendige änderungen zu
beschließen das wird nächste woche
montag wird der bundesarbeitsminister
ein konzept dazu vorliegen ich hoffe
dass wir uns dann auch einigen können
gerade bei der unterbringung gibt es
erhebliche mängel das haben wir jetzt ja
alle mitbekommen das muss dann geschaut
werden werde an die verantwortlichkeit
genommen wird ich kann ihnen jedenfalls
sagen dass auch ich nicht zufrieden bin
mit dem was wir da jetzt gesehen haben
bei der umsetzung der dinge auch für
diese saison arbeitskräfte sind
natürlich jeweils dann auch die vor ort
zuständigen behörden für die kontrolle
zuständig und die arbeitgeber eben auch
dafür dass sie sich an die bestimmungen
halten wo das nicht der fall ist das hat
die bundeslandwirtschaftsministern auch
gesagt muss gehandelt werden nachfrage
ja gerne frau bundeskanzlerin ich würde
gerne noch mal drauf eingehen die
arbeits und sozialministerkonferenz hat
in einer protokollerklärung genau auf
diese datenlage hingewiesen und acht
bundesländer haben gegen gezeichnet in
dem sie die bundesregierung auffordern
dafür sorge zu tragen dass die daten die
bis jetzt an die gesundheits anderen
nicht geliefert worden sind dass
sichergestellt werden dass diese
datenlage geklärt wird und zurzeit wird
sie würden deutschen bauernverband
ja also wenn die bundesländer nicht
selber zuständig sind die länder die
daten herbeizuführen also manchmal
warten auf ihr als bundesregierung auf
daten es ist jetzt nicht so dass nur
immer die bundesregierung daten liefern
muss aber wo wir das beibringen können
werden wir auch uns darum bemühen dass
wir das tun und was die zahl der saison
arbeiter anbelangt sind wir ja sowieso
haben wir ein festes kontingent da ist
ja eine feste zeit klar das ist auch
klar wo die leute hingegangen sind also
ich bin jetzt glaube da müsste die
datenlage klar sein in der
fleischindustrie vielleicht nicht ganz
so manuel höferlin fdp stellt die
nächste folgen
vielen dank herr präsident sehr geehrte
frau bundeskanzlerin
wir haben wir von ihnen hat eben auch
gehört wie wichtig die korona tracing
app sein kann in der nachverfolgung von
kontakten auch von kontakt ketten von
infektionsketten jetzt ist es ja so dass
nicht erst seit gerade eben an einer
solchen app gearbeitet wird sondern
eigentlich seit nunmehr fast sieben
wochen dass wir über sieben wochen
wenn man den beginnen sieht und diese
corona tracing app ist soweit ich das
verstanden habe federführend im
gesundheitsministerium angesiedelt hat
man von ihnen als bundesregierung gehört
na ja es wird jetzt auch an ein
konsortium von sap und die systems
gegeben
ich würde gerne von ihnen wissen warum
ausgerechnet im kanzleramt jetzt vor
allen dingen auch unter starker
einbindung des bundespresseamts die
gesundheits app faktisch geführt und
entwickelt wird es bestimmte gründe dass
hier jetzt neue maßnahmen getroffen
werden wie die app vorangetrieben wird
weil irgendwie haben wir jetzt heute
gehört im juni soll sie fertig werden
das ist ja nicht wirklich voran tragen
na gut der kanzleramtsminister war ja
gestern bei ihnen weiß nicht ob sie gar
nicht über die app gesprochen haben aber
wir können es ja auch noch mal tun
das kanzleramt hat im allgemeinen eine
koordinierende funktion bei allen
projekten der bundesregierung das
gesundheitsministerium ist zuständig für
die fragen des datenschutzes ist das
bundesinnenministerium zuständig und das
kanzleramt hat sich auch darum gekümmert
wir sie wissen dass wir verschiedene
ansätze verfolgen könnten wir haben uns
jetzt für den dezentral
ansatz entschieden frankreich zb für
einen zentralen ansatz das ist erstmal
eine allgemeine architektur entwickelt
worden wie jetzt für den dezentralen
ansatz weil wir glauben dass es dafür
eine sehr viel höhere akzeptanz gibt und
dass solche entwicklungsarbeiten dauern
können ist jetzt auch nichts neues ist
es muss einen großen vertrauensbeweis
liefern diese app und ich bin sehr froh
dass telekom und sap jetzt ja auch
inmitten dieses projekt eingestiegen
sind
wir brauchen die schnittstellen für die
betriebssysteme betreiber für die
mehrheit der handys die werden erst in
diesen tagen bereit gestellt und ich
glaube aber dass die arbeiten jetzt mit
nachdruck hochdruck laufen aber hier
gilt für mich auch natürlich
gründlichkeit muss gewährleistet sein
und datenschutz muss gewährleistet sein
sind alle datenschutzbehörden dass bse
sowohl als auch der
datenschutzbeauftragte mit in die arbeit
eingebunden nachfrage gerne ja sie sind
darauf eingegangen dass das kanzleramt
ja koordiniert würden sie trotzdem nicht
erklären oder uns warum über die
codierung rolle hinaus plötzlich
innerhalb des kanzleramts dinge
entschieden werden oder können sie das
bestätigen dass es so ist dass man das
design der app die das ist die
farbgebung der name von der korona waren
es jetzt plötzlich im kanzleramt
entschieden werden und nicht bei
denjenigen die sie entwickeln zum
beispiel telekom oder sap hat es einen
bestimmten grund und vielleicht können
sie noch eine sache sagen wenn wir jetzt
so lange warten
dass das am ende später kommt würden sie
sagen dass die krone app noch vor einem
impfstoff kommen kann oder kommt sicher
danach also ich glaube schon dass die
noch vor einem impfstoff kommen kann
wenn jetzt nicht also solche wunder
können eigentlich mit dem impfstoff
nicht mehr passieren ich glaube sie
kommt vorher das kann nicht zusagen und
ehrlich gesagt haben sich sap und
telekom beschwert dass wir auf ihre
designvorschlägen nicht eingehen oder
das bundespresseamt ist sozusagen für
die bewerbung von produkten hinter denen
die bundesregierung auch steht zuständig
dazu gibt es die entsprechenden
agenturen die machen vorschläge und da
entscheidet sich das kanzleramt sondern
erscheint wieder alle zuständigen
ressorts und nach meinem kenntnisstand
haben wir
auch sehr friedlich gemacht also wenn
sich jemand bei ihm beschwert hat sagen
sie es mir vielleicht haben wir den
vergessen mal kenne ich mein cdu so ist
der nächste frage selber ja sehr geehrte
frau bundeskanzlerin in meinem heimat
kreis coesfeld sind in den letzten tagen
die infektionszahlen ja in die höhe
geschossen und es ärgert mich massiv
dass aufgrund verfehlungen in einem
unternehmen stichwort westfleisch die
disziplin der menschen vor ort mit füßen
getreten wird und es ärgert mich auch
dass gastronomen jetzt darunter leiden
unter der verlängerung des showdowns und
es ärgert mich auch dass jetzt landwirte
plötzlich in die röhre gucken müssen und
als abgeordneter dieses kreises habe ich
schon die erwartung dass wir jetzt
natürlich auch knallhart die quarantäne
durchsetzen glaube dass teil noch alle
verantwortlichen behörden vor ort
und ich halte es auch für wichtig dass
über unterbringung noch mal diskutieren
und sie haben das ja auch gerade
angedeutet
und dieses mal vorausgeschickt meine
frage sie haben am 6 mai in der runde
mit den länder-regierungschefs ja
abgesprochen dass es im falle von
regional klar eingrenzbar 'ran
infektionsgeschehen und da wird das
altenheim als einrichtung beispielhaft
häufig zitiert ausnahmetatbestände geben
kann für lockerungen trotz eines
anstiegs ist in diesem zusammenhang auch
darüber nachgedacht worden solche fälle
auf unternehmen wie westfleisch und
solche infektionsgeschehen zu
erschrecken erstrecken
damit wir den menschen vor ort jetzt
hoffnung machen können dass auch sie
nicht allzu lange unter den
restriktionen noch leiden müssen danke
also die entscheidung darüber dass es ja
ein beschluss den wir gemeinsam mit dem
ministerpräsidenten gefällt haben
treffen ja die landesregierung in
absprache mit den landräten also mit den
örtlichen behörden und einrichtungen
sind in der tat pflegeheime oder
krankenhäuser oder eben auch ein betrieb
aber in diesem fall ist es natürlich
nicht nicht der betrieb allein sondern
sind eben auch die unterbringung der
beschäftigten und damit ist es dann doch
etwas größer
streut die das infektionsrisiko als wenn
es nur in diesem betrieb wäre und
niemand den betrieb verlassen würde
das heißt also man hat sich entschlossen
für eine bestimmte zeit die
lockerungsmaßnahmen die sonst in
nordrhein westfalen gelten auszusetzen
und ich hoffe dass mit den sehr
entschieden vorgehen für das ich auch
sehr dankbar wenn der landesregierungen
der örtlichen behörden dann auch sehr
schnell die infektion jetzt wieder
eingegrenzt werden können nachfrage
angehe kollege harald weinberg die linke
als nächstes recht eine frage zu stellen
vielen herzlichen dank herr vorsitzender
frau bundeskanzlerin ich in krankenhaus
politischer sprecher meiner fraktion
habe insofern sehr viel mit
pflegekräften zu tun in dauert mit ihnen
auch in der diskussion
es gibt ja einige situationen wo man
sagen kann da gibt es arbeitsschutz
verstöße da gibt es probleme was die
schutzausrüstung und betrifft und
ähnliches im sinne von learning lessons
wäre gibt es da eine forderung von den
pflegekräften die lautet es wäre ganz
gut wenn wir so etwas hätten wir eine
unabhängige unabhängigen krisen
monitoring wo verbände drin sind wo die
gewerkschaften drin sind wo
pflegeverbände drin sind wo auch
durchaus die arbeitgeberseite drin ist
die deutsche krankenhaus gesellschaft
die solche fälle einfach sozusagen auch
mal auflistet und darauf sozusagen
lagebeurteilung macht für eventuell
zukünftig auftretende ereignisse dieser
art das würden sie von einer solchen
idee halten
also ich denke wenn wir die pandemie mal
überwunden haben dann
wird man sehr dankbar sein für alle
beteiligten gruppen dass sie uns ihre
gelernten dinge mitteilen
je verbands übergreifender also von
arbeitgeberverbänden dass arbeitgeber
verwenden das ist umso aussagekräftiger
oder umso einfacher ist auch für die
regierung daraus die schlüsse zu ziehen
wir werden das selber auch tun denn wir
haben ja auch schwachstellen entdeckt ob
es nun die produktion von masten ist
strategische unabhängigkeit bestimmte
fragen die auch das miteinander von bund
ländern und kommunen anbelangt das große
thema stärkung des öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienstes also wir werden alle
gut daran tun und ich werde jede
anregung sehr gerne mit aufnehmen
nach nur eine kurze nachfrage weil
eigentlich würde das ja bedeuten dass
man es jetzt einrichtet nach möglichkeit
mit einer sozialen dieses learning
lessons halt eben auch hinbekommen wenn
man es im nachhinein gut dann hat man
natürlich die erfahrungen die man
eventuell einbringen kann
aber jetzt sind ja die ereignisse auch
in den krankenhäusern und pflegeheimen
vor ort also wenn sie die gruppe haben
und die möchte zusammenarbeiten dann und
mir jede woche einen lagebericht
schicken werde ich die nicht nur
annehmen sondern auch interessierte
lesen und versuchen die erfahrung damit
einfließen zu lassen ich bin ja ein
aufmerksamer mensch und nicht genosse zu
sagen so nicht eingreifen
insofern schauen sie ich möchte dass das
alles möglichst gut funktioniert und
insbesondere wenn wir jetzt über die
älteren menschen denken in den
pflegeheimen
die sind doch zum großen teil wirklich
diejenigen die mit am herzen getroffen
sind keine besucher ganz wenig kontakte
wir haben jetzt gesagt wenigstens eine
feste kontaktperson genauso
behinderteneinrichtungen und wenn der da
nicht aufmerksam während überlegen
würden was können wir tun um dieses
leben auch etwas zu erleichtern und
schöner zu machen genauso wie das der
dort beschäftigten dann wäre das doch
nicht in ordnung also ich bin da sehr
aufnahmebereit
danke sehr tabea rößner bündnis 90/die
grünen zählt die nächste frage ja vielen
dank herr vorsitzender frau
bundeskanzlerin ich möchte mich auf
einen oder auch medienberichte von der
vergangenen woche beziehen und zwar ging
es darum die ermittlungserfolge in
sachen bundestags heck es gab ja vor
fünf jahren sie erinnern sich einen
großen hacker angriff auf den bundestag
hinter sind man schätzt so 16 gigabyte
daten dokumente e mails abgegriffen
worden unter anderem ist ja auch ihr
büro ihr abgeordnetenbüro davon
betroffen gewesen
und ich nehme an sie teilen unserer
einschätzung dass zu so einem
ermittlungserfolg die zusammenarbeit mit
den ausländischen geheimdiensten sich
bewährt und es außerhalb des instruments
eines hacks erfolgreiche cyber abwehr
möglich ist ich wollte sie aber fragen
ob die erkenntnisse haben welche daten
und vor allen dingen zu welchem zweck
die von ihrem büro abgegriffen worden
sind nein also ich hab den ägypter wurde
relativ wahllos abgegriffen
was man kriegen konnte ich bin sehr froh
dass die untersuchung doch jetzt dazu
geführt haben dass der
generalbundesanwalt eine konkrete person
auch auf die fahndungsliste gesetzt hat
nehmen diese dinge sehr ernst weil ich
glaube dass da sehr ordentlich
recherchiert wurde und ich darf sehr
ehrlich sagen mich schmerzt dass auf der
einen seite bemühe ich mich tagtäglich
auch um ein besseres verhältnis zu
russland
und wenn man dann auf der anderen seite
sieht das so harte evidenzen dafür gibt
dass da auch russische kräfte daran sind
sofort zu gehen dann ist das schon ein
spannungsfeld in dem wir da arbeiten in
dem wunsch nach guten beziehungen zu
russland dass auch ich nicht ganz aus
meinem inneren streichen kann das ist
unangenehm und wir werden alles tun um
natürlich den wünschen des gba auch zu
entsprechenden nachfrage ja vielleicht
dazu genau die nachfrage zu welcher
neuen einschätzung kommen sie dann in
der bewertung und der zusammenarbeit mit
dem russischen geheimdienst gerade im
hinblick darauf dass es diese verbindung
dieses mutmaßlichen täters gibt der ja
ganz eindeutig offenbar mit fans
militärgeheimdienst er und so weiter
zusammengearbeitet hat oder arbeitet ja
leider ist die englische einschätzung zu
der ich komme nicht so neu weil es eine
facette in einer vielzahl von facetten
gibt es gibt eine strategie russlands
die müssen wir beachten und die können
auch nicht einfach verdrängen der
hybriden kriegsführung die auch
kriegsführung im zusammenhang mit cyber
desorientierung fakten verdrehung
beinhaltet das ist nicht nur irgendwie
ein zufallsprodukt ist es durchaus eine
strategie die dort angewandt wird
trotzdem werde ich mich weiter um gutes
verhältnis zu russland bemühen weil ich
glaube dass das allen grund gibt diese
diplomatischen bemühungen immer
fortzusetzen aber es macht das natürlich
nicht einfach da hat so eine nachfolge
kollege das nachfrage zu lassen ich habe
noch nie regiert sie sagen der vorgang
ist ihnen unangenehm
das ist jetzt ein ich glaub so nah war
seit ihrem niemand mehr einen strand der
geheimdienst an einem bundeskanzler der
bundesrepublik deutschland
ich finde den vorgang schon eher
ungeheuerlich ist dass ihnen nur
unangenehm oder haben sie beim
außenminister und weiteren auch über
maßnahmen gesprochen die irgendeine
folge
des landes da zu lassen wurde möglich
machen weil ich finde den vorgang schon
ehrlich gesagt für dieses land mehr als
unangenehm
genau aber unangenehm ist eine facette
ungeheuerlich finde ich ihnen nebenbei
auch aber es ist halt bin ja auch nicht
die einzige betroffene des deutschen
bundestages gewesen sondern das waren ja
viele kollegen abgeordneten für die gilt
das ungeheuerliche genauso und es stört
natürlich eine vertrauensvolle
zusammenarbeit und sie wissen dass wir
im zusammenhang mit dem mord im
tiergarten ja auch sanktionen also
ausweisungen ergriffen haben wir haben
jetzt hier an dieser stelle erst mal die
aufgabe zu versuchen auch die person
durch verhandlungen zu finden aber
natürlich behalten wir uns immer
maßnahmen vor auch gegen russland um das
deutlich zu machen
sein kollege spangenberg kfd stellt die
nächste folge fielen 1 frau
bundeskanzlerin die analyse des
auswertungsbericht ist aus dem bmi von
25 24 in kommentierung von neuen
bedeuten wissenschaftlern zeigt in
schonungsloser offenheit dass sie
eingeleiteten maßnahmen im rahmen der
korona problematik völlig überzogen
waren und sind insbesondere wird in
diesem bericht die formulierung
fehlalarm festgestellt wie erklären sie
den tausenden wirtschaftlich
geschädigten in deutschland und die
offenbar unnötigen einschränkungen der
grundrechte
diese fehleinschätzung der regierung und
welche personellen und politischen
maßnahmen werden sie daraus ziehen
vielen dank sie wissen ja sicherlich
dass die regierung die einschätzung die
in diesem papier geäußert wurde nicht
teilt und dass wir zu anderen
bewertungen gekommen sind wir wissen
dass es menschen gibt die müssen unter
den einschränkungen leiden haben
in der ersten frage hier schon darüber
gesprochen arbeitsplätze sind in gefahr
die wirtschaft geht durch eine rezession
das ist klar wir müssen immer wieder
gucken wie ist die verhältnismäßigkeit
unserer maßnahmen gegeben wir sind zu
der überzeugung gekommen dass diese
maßnahmen richtig waren genauso wie es
richtig ist jetzt schrittweise zu
lockern um einfach eine völlige
überforderung oder überwältigung unseres
gesundheitssystems zu verhindern und das
ist die gemeinsame haltung der
bundesregierung und auch des
bundesinnenministeriums und das hat das
bundesinnenministerium auch deutlich
gemacht eingesehen
nächste frage stellt kollegin nina
scheer spd
sehr geehrte frau bundeskanzlerin in
ihrer rede zum petersberger klimadialog
hatten sie am 28 april ausdrücklich
begrüßt dass die mission reduktionen im
vergleich zu 1990 um 50 bis 55 prozent
erfolgen soll
wie ist das vereinbar mit den jüngsten
papier der cdu csu fraktion in der
dieses ziel nicht mitgetragen wird
es wird darauf verwiesen dass man dazu
ein ausgleich in der eu bräuchte und
alle wissen dass das sehr schwer ist ein
lastenausgleich wie ist das vereinbar
und es ist für mich auch die frage wie
unsere fraktion wie ist es vereinbart
diese äußerungen die wir ja begrüßen auf
den petersberger klimadialog mit der
anhaltenden verweigerung der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion in solar
decke abzuschaffen
na jetzt muss ich ein bisschen sortieren
also erst mal hat die cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion gestern ein klima
papier verabschiedet in dem sie sich zur
klimaneutralität im jahre 2050 bekannt
hat und ich glaube die bundesregierung
hat ja auch mit unterstützung des
parlaments eine vielzahl von maßnahmen
ergriffen wir werden noch weitere
ergreifen müssen um die zwischen ziele
auch zu erreichen dass das zweite ist
dass es um die frage geht wie wird die
europäische union in ihrer zielsetzung
sich weiterentwickeln
die kommissionspräsident dann hat gesagt
dass sie das ziel 2030 anheben will von
40 prozent auf 50 bis 55 prozent
das habe ich begrüßt und die unions
fraktion sagt dass dazu aber auch neue
verhandlungen zur lastenverteilung
geführt werden müssen und das ist für
mich ganz selbstverständlich wir haben
mitgliedstaaten die haben zum beispiel
bis 2030 reduktions raten die sogar bei
null liegen wenn ich mich recht erinnere
und ich glaube wenn wir alle miteinander
in der europäischen union die
klimaneutralität 2050 erreichen wollen
dann wird man mit einem ziel
reduktionsziel 2030 0
auch sicherlich nicht hinkommen das
heißt es wird ganz automatisch unter den
mitgliedsstaaten und ich gebe ihnen
recht es wird schwer
es war auch bis jetzt
guten verhandlungen nicht leichter
werden wird es verschiebungen geben und
auch unterschiedliche lastenteilung die
bundesregierung sich da die
bundesrepublik wird sich daran
beteiligen aber es kann nicht sein dass
der schlüssel von 2020 oder 17 als wir
verhandelt haben jetzt einfach so bleibt
2 unter der letzte punkt war der pv
decke da ist es so sie wissen dass es
mühselig in der tat aber hoffentlich
irgendwann ende verhandlungen über die
frage der windenergie gibt und es gibt
dann die politische zusage dass der pv
deckel aufbohren jetzt daran ändert sich
auch nichts angesehen die
bundeskanzlerin hat jetzt etwas mehr
zeit bekommen wenn sie ja zugleich für
die cdu/csu-fraktion antworten wo ist
sie aber sie haben einen nachfragen
deren mitglied die bundeskanzlerin ist
wieder deren mitglied die
bundeskanzlerin ja sehr großer tresor
auf also frau kollegin cher liebe frau
merkel wollen sie dann den widerspruch
auflösen denen wir ja hier ab hut haben
wird schon jetzt drohenden
arbeitsplatzverluste wenn der solar
deckel und das nationale beispiel dann
auch in der europäischen union droht zu
scheitern
wenn wir nicht unmittelbar handeln wir
brauchen diese woche wir das erneuerbare
energien gesetz auf der tagesordnung und
insofern wäre schon auch noch mal eine
frage ob sie zu kennen es nehmen das
auch international inzwischen dringend
appelliert wird auch im kontext von
konjunkturprogrammen den schwerpunkt auf
den ausbau erneuerbarer energien zu
setzen
ja und ich werde auch morgen die
gelegenheiten in der vorbereitung des
bundesrates wieder nutzen um noch mal
mit dem ministerpräsidenten auch zu
sprechen im blick auf die windenergie
damit wir diese frage schnellstmöglich
lösen ich stimme ihnen zu
wir sollten hier baldmöglichst eine
lösung finden ich werde mich auch dafür
einsetzen das ist ihnen zu lange dauert
verstehe ich auch noch da ein gesetz
dazu möchte die kollegin lisa barth und
bündnis 90 die grünen eine frage stellen
sehr geehrte frau bundeskanzlerin ich
möchte auch gern zur lastenverteilung
der eu fragen und insbesondere vor dem
hintergrund dessen dass sie vor kurzem
angemahnt haben dass wir in der korona
krise mehr europäische zusammenarbeit
brauchen solidarität und zusammenhalt
finde ich ist serbe wunderlich und sehr
befremdlich dass sie nur noch in ihrem
beitrag gerade vorschlagen dass
deutschland ein geringeren klima beitrag
leistet dass wir also bei dieser
klimaziel erhöhung einen längeren
beitrag einbringen das wäre eher das
gegenteil von mehr solidarität und mehr
verantwortung daher die frage an sie
welche fakten haben sich dahingehend
geändert dass deutschland jetzt ein
jüngere geringeren beitrag einbringt
meines wissens nach sind wir immer noch
der größte co2 emittent in der
europäischen union mit unserem pro kopf
verbrauch im zehn tonnen sind wir auch
in der spitzengruppe dabei
wir sind der größte emittent wir müssen
unserer ansicht nach
auch verantwortung übernehmen was hat
sie aus ihrer sicht geändert waren
weniger solidarität weniger
verantwortung von deutscher sicht jetzt
also erstens wir sind in der tat in der
spitzengruppe beim pro-kopf-verbrauch
deshalb haben wir auch uns sehr intensiv
mit dem kohleausstieg beschäftigt
zweitens wir sind natürlich der größte
emittent weil wir die meisten einwohner
haben aber beim pro kopf verbrauch gibt
es auch andere spitzen länder und wir
sind uns doch sicherlich eigentlich wenn
die europäische union der erste co2
emittieren
der erste kontinent sein will der kein
co2 mehr emittiert dass dann alle länder
auf null kommen müssen
das heißt auch andere länder werden in
ihrer ambitionen weiter gehen müssen und
dass man bevor der kommissionsvorschlag
vorliegt bereits zusagen national wir
machen wie immer das was wir gemacht
haben und andere werden gar nicht
gefragt was sie machen das wäre doch
taktisch wirklich unklug und deshalb
kann und muss über die lastenverteilung
neu verteilt verhandelt werden das ist
klar
das wird auch im europäischen rat
geschehen so ist es jedes mal gewesen
ist es auch beim vorletzten mal eine
andere lastenverteilung gewesen als beim
letzten mal und es wird beim nächsten
mal wieder eine andere sein dass
deutschland dazu beitragen muss da
gibt's doch gar keine frage
wir haben im übrigen ziel von 55 prozent
reduktion das wissen sie andere haben
das nicht
johannes vogel fdp stellt den ex titan
ist ein nationales ziel
sehr geehrte frau bundeskanzlerin sie
haben zu recht darauf hingewiesen dass
in der wirtschaftlichen dimension dieser
krise und der sozialstaat schützt und
ich denke wir sind einer meinung dass
wir auf eine solide finanzierung des
sozialstaats achten müssen
sie haben 2008 und der letzten großen
krise die rentengarantie eingeführt und
damals wurde mit vereinbart dass wenn
diese greift in den folgenden jahren das
verrechnet wird so dass renten und löhne
immer im gleichklang steigen
jetzt haben heute in der süddeutschen
zeitung noch mal die professoren börsch
supan und rürup darauf hingewiesen dass
sie im renten paket 2018 den effekt dass
der sogenannte nachholfaktor ausgesetzt
haben
und das kann natürlich dazu führen dass
wir nächstes jahr sehr wahrscheinlich
wieder die renten
greift das dann in den folgejahren ist
nicht verrechnet wird und das dazu führt
dass auf dauer die renten stärker
steigen als die löhne
und meine frage ist jetzt halten sie das
für fair ist das mit blick auf die
generationengerechtigkeit eigentlich
unverantwortbar und müsste man nicht
jetzt den nachholfaktor wieder in kraft
setzen also wieder einführen also ich
habe heute früh über diese entdeckung
der renten professoren gelesen wenn
solchen renommierten professoren das
jetzt erst auffällt dann ist verzeihen
sie vielleicht dass ich in den
verbliebenen vier stunden zeit nehmen
noch nicht das gesetz gelesen habe ich
hatte mit hubertus heil habe heute
soviel über die fleischindustrie zu
sprechen aber ich habe mir fest
vorgenommen das zu tun
wenn das so wäre wie das heute in der
zeitung stand dass der nachholfaktor bis
2025 ausgesetzt ist würden wir darüber
natürlich noch mal reden
das hängt dann aber mit den haltelinien
die wir eingezogen haben zusammen und
wie man das dann löst muss man sehen
ich muss aber erstmal gucken ob das
faktoren bestimmt und zweitens ist dann
der nachholfaktor auch nicht für immer
ausgesetzt also das will ich dann auch
noch mal sagen und übrigen führt der
nachholfaktor ja dann dazu dass die lenz
renten nicht mehr so stark steigen wie
die löhne also die renten stiegen dann
langsamer weil man ja nachholen muss was
man bei den löhnen geben
nicht angeglichen hat weil man die rente
hätte kurzzeitig senken müssen was
keiner möchte also ich stehe zu dieser
rentengarantie
ich werde der sache nachgehen falls es
so ist gilt ist nur bis 25 und nicht für
immer und glücklicherweise sind wir auch
noch nicht in der situation dass die
renten sinken sondern diesem jahr
steigen sie mit über deutlich über drei
prozent für die menschen in den alten
bundesländern mit über 4% für die
menschen in den neuen bundesländern
darüber und ich halte nichts von den
vorschlägen die sagen das sollte man
jetzt nicht machen
in vorauseilende antizipieren dessen was
vielleicht kommen könnte die
rentnerinnen und rentner haben das
verdient davon auch nicht sondern ich
bin sehr für die rentensteigerung dieses
jahr aber eben dafür dass das
langfristig immer im gleichklang steigt
ich habe es mir schon angeschaut und es
ist in der tat so dass selbst wenn die
haltelinie noch nicht erreicht ist also
das rentengarantie über 48 prozent liegt
das dann für die folgenden jahre der
nachholfaktor ausgesetzt ist sollte ihre
prüfung der faktenlage zu demselben
urteil kommen wie meine wären sie dann
mit mir der meinung dass dann definitiv
der nachholfaktor sofern es oberhalb der
haltelinie liegt wieder in kraft gesetzt
werden müsste und alles andere mit blick
auf die generationengerechtigkeit
unverantwortbare wäre für diese
meinungsbildung brauche ich noch ein
paar stunden herr vogel aber ich werde
sie dann in form
danke sehr gunther krichbaum cdu csu
stellt die nächste frage ja vielen dank
herr präsident frau bundeskanzlerin die
korona krise die korona pandemie hat uns
an vielen stellen in europa kalt
erwischt an welchen stellen es sehen sie
die notwendigkeit zu stärkeren
europäischen ansätzen bei der bekämpfung
von pandemien zu kommen weil es ja für
die zukunft eben nicht ausgeschlossen
werden kann dass uns ähnliche
krankheitsverläufe ähnliche pandemien
noch einmal heimsuchen können
ja ich glaube dass wir mit der tatsache
dass gesundheitspolitik erst einmal
zuständigkeit der mitgliedstaaten ist
weiter leben können also das müssen wir
nicht vergemeinschaften uns meiner sicht
aber wir brauchen schon ein paar bessere
europäische mechanismen und wir sehen
wie schnell ich sag gleich was dazu und
wir sehen wie schnell natürlich in folge
solcher beschränkungen zum beispiel die
wir einführen mussten um die
überforderung des gesundheitssystems zu
verhindern dann auch andere bereiche die
sehr europäisch sind wie zum beispiel
das funktionieren des binnenmarktes
betroffen sind und da ist glaube ich
erkennbar dass ein sehr viel bessere
informationen gegenseitig erfolgen muss
um lkw schlangen wie wir sie gesehen
haben zu verhindern um unabgesprochene
grenzschließung zu verhindern und vieles
andere mehr
und wir brauchen mit sicherheit auch im
blick auf die gesundheit eine stärkere
strategische souveränität europas wenn
es zb um medizinische versorgung geht
wenn es um
masken in diesem falle geht also da
werden wir auch den langen reihe von
lehren daraus ziehen müssen und sind ja
auch schon dabei sie daraus zu ziehen
wir selber haben schmerzlich erfahren
als wir durch durchaus durch gute gründe
ich spaß nächste mal zehn sekunden durch
gute gründe gesagt haben wir machen ein
limitiertes exportverbot medizinische
güter die wir uns zum teil auch ins
eigene fleisch geschnitten haben weil
wir dann gemerkt haben wie wir von
zulieferungen abhängig sind und das
alles nochmal zu reflektieren das wird
sicherlich die aufgabe sein diese
nachfrage eine eine kurze nachfrage
wir sind institutionell durchaus dafür
gerüstet in europa wir haben eine so
genannte e cdc dass es die anti
seuchenbekämpfung agentur oder
eigentlich solchen agentur in der nähe
von stockholm eine agentur die im
windschatten fristet die eigentlich kaum
bekannt ist aber hielten sie es für
denkbar dass wir analog frontex diese
agentur auch entsprechend zu einer
veritablen behörde pardon entwickeln
können
denn frontex war früher auch eine simple
agenturen in anführungszeichen aber es
fehlt eben doch auch auf das wir
institutionell einfach hier wenig
gerüstet waren in europa wir haben heute
gerade im kabinett sehr lange über diese
agentur gesprochen weil sie zum beispiel
europaweit auch die das
infektionsgeschehen abbildet und auch
warnstufen ausgibt auch weltweit und die
diesem agentur sollte auf jeden fall
stärker bewegt werden in dieser pandemie
eine noch wichtigere rolle und
koordinierende und von allen
mitgliedstaaten akzeptierte rolle zu
spielen damit man auch zu gleichen
entscheidungskriterien kommen kann
jetzt habe ich noch zwei nachfragen zu
diesem thema einmal vom vdr brandner
könnte sollten die grünen vorsitzende
ehrte frau bundeskanzlerin ich bin froh
dass wir vernehmen konnten dass jetzt
alle grenzübergänge wieder geöffnet
werden sie haben das gerade selber
erwähnt dass grenzkontrollen aber
stichprobenartig oder auch weiter
gefasst noch weiter vorgehalten werden
sollen
ich habe eine konkrete frage an sie bis
jetzt ist grenzüberschreitendes reisen
als einreise zum ehepartner und
eingetragenen lebenspartner möglich was
wollen sie dafür tun dass jene die nach
einem erweiterten familienbegriff leben
also partnerschaft ohne trauschein dass
diese sich auch in den nächsten wochen
sehen können wenn diese grenzkontrollen
weiterlaufen also der
bundesinnenminister hatte dargelegt dass
genau das gewollt wird da gibt es dann
immer die schöne formulierung werden das
glaubhaft gemacht werden kann
das ist in zeiten von kommune eine
gewisse schwierigkeit vielleicht
manchmal wenn ich dann so leicht sagen
darf aber ansonsten
sind wir der meinung dass das geschehen
soll und es sind wird jetzt ja auch nur
noch stichprobenweise kontrolliert in
den nächsten tagen also nicht mehr so
flächendeckend wie das jetzt der fall
war
also ich hoffe dass diese in der tat
sehr beschwerlichen situationen für
menschen die auf beiden seiten der
grenze gelebt haben oder leben jetzt
überwunden werden können und das ziel
ist ja auch wenn das infektionsgeschehen
das zuletzt das will ich ausdrücklich
noch mal sagen dass dann ab 15 06 diese
grenzkontrollen im schengen-raum auch
vollständig entfallen können der kollege
de erschienen war
fdp möchte ja auch keine frage denn
abstellen vielen dank herr präsident ist
die frage zu lassen der bundeskanzlerin
ist schließlich direkt an
wir sprachen darüber direkt ganz
beziehung oder verwandte und ähnliches
ich gehe fast die frage mal weiter sind
sie nicht der meinung dass also
grenzschließung grenzkontrollen
außerordentlich wenig beitragen können
zur eindämmung der pandemie mindestens
gegen bei solchen ländern die ein
ähnliches infektionsgeschehen haben wie
wir glauben sie dass die durch
grenzkontrollen die pandemie nennenswert
aufhalten können ich glaube dass zwei
dinge eine rolle spielen einmal die
vergleichbarkeit desinfektions
geschehens und zum anderen die frage der
vergleichbarkeit der maßnahmen
wenn das war ja der auslöser letztlich
der deutsch-französischen
grenzkontrollen dann auch der letzte
wenn zum beispiel in frankreich schon
ihr leben geschlossen waren und die
restaurants geschlossen waren dann gibt
es plötzlich eine große bewegung
richtung deutschland das könnte aber
umgekehrt genauso sein
das heißt wir müssen auch ein bisschen
auf die reziprozität der maßnahmen
achten das heißt im zusammenhang mit
frankreich war während der zeit als dann
der ganze lockdown dort eingeführt wurde
natürlich überhaupt nicht mehr die
situation gegeben wie an dem tag an dem
die grenzkontrollen eingeführt wurden
dazwischen lagen leider nur zwei tage
und daraus hat sich dann ja auch die
veränderte betrachtungsweise ergeben
also reziprozität der maßnahmen wir
haben keine grenzkontrollen gehabt
zwischen nrw niedersachsen
den niederlanden zum beispiel und das
hat nur geklappt über ostern weil man
miteinander gesprochen hat und gesagt
hat wenn der eine die freizeitparks zu
hat muss der andere auf die freizeit zu
haben sonst kommt es zu einem zu einer
mobilität die wir dann nicht mehr genau
überblicken dass es dort sehr gut
gelungen und das wird uns jetzt auch mit
frankreich gut gelegen ich habe dem
präsidenten auch selbst drüber
gesprochen
die nächste frage gestellte kollege
fabio de masi die linke vielen dank herr
präsident
frau bundeskanzlerin viele menschen sind
ja verständlicherweise verzweifelt in
der korona krise alleinerziehende die
nicht wissen wie sie ihre arbeit
erledigen sollen gleichzeitig die kinder
betreuen es soll sogar kinder in
deutschland geben die schule vermissen
aber es ist ja so dass das vor allem
auch die leute sind die nicht immer vom
leben geküsst werden die kassiererin die
pflegekräfte die jetzt den laden am
laufen halten gleichzeitig ist jetzt
bald hauptversammlung von bmw die
schippen dividenden aus unter anderem an
die quantum klattens über 700 millionen
euro die quandts um klattens tauchen ja
auch immer wieder in parteispenden
berichten auf und gleichzeitig werden
zehntausende von beschäftigten in
kurzarbeit geschickt jetzt weiß ich dass
kurzarbeit eine versicherungsleistung
ist aber es ist ja durchaus auch möglich
dass wir noch zuschüsse aus dem
bundeshaushalt brauchen für die
arbeitslosenversicherung vor diesem
hintergrund möchte ich sie fragen ob sie
die auffassung ihres finanzministers
teilen dass diejenigen die starke
schultern haben in diesem land mehr
leisten müssen für den wiederaufbau des
landes und sie zu belangen zum beispiel
mit einer vermögensabgabe wie wir das
schon mal in deutschland hatten nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg mit einem
lastenausgleich also ich weiß nicht ob
der finanzminister sich schon dezidiert
für eine vermögensabgabe ausgesprochen
hat ich spreche mich nicht für eine
vermögensabgabe aus ich finde erst mal
wichtig dass wir noch ein paar
unternehmen haben die auch steuern
zahlen an den start denn sonst können
wir auch den dienst nicht gut geht
leider nicht so viel hilfe leisten wie
wir das gerne würden und deshalb solange
alles auf der basis der legalität
stattfindet und auch parteispenden sind
sozusagen rechtlich möglich werden sogar
unterstützt von dem steuerzahler wir
parteien wichtig finden wie sie ja
sicherlich auch nachvollziehen können
also wir brauchen unternehmen die
gewinne machen damit steuern gezahlt
werden wir brauchen eine stärkere
belastung der starken schultern als der
schwächeren schultern das ist vollkommen
klar dass das die grundlage unseres
sozialstaates und in diesem rahmen der
in den diskussionen auch für die zukunft
führen nachfrage
die fragen wer die lasten in diesem land
trägt wird uns noch eine weile
beschäftigen sie haben in der letzten
finanzkrise sich mit herrn steinbrück
damals vor die kameras gestellt und
gesagt die spareinlagen sind in
deutschland sicher wären sie denn bereit
sich auch mit herrn scholz vor die
kameras zu stellen und ein versprechen
abzugeben für ihre amtszeit dass keine
renten keine sozialen leistungen gekürzt
werden
ich sage immer wieder und sagt das auch
heute hier gerne dass die steinbrücks
märkische sparer garantie ford gilt
durchaus gründe soll sie grüßen stellt
die nächste frage
sehr geehrter herr präsident lieber frau
bundeskanzlerin wie bewerten sie die
aktuellen auswirkungen der korona krise
auf die gleichberechtigung erste
wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse deuten
darauf hin dass ein großer teil der
frauen insbesondere mütter von einer
andauernden mehrfachbelastung von
homeschooling von kinderbetreuung oft
eben neben ihrer eigentlichen
berufstätigkeit betroffen ist und in den
sozialen medien schildern zahlreiche
frauen sehr viele frauen von ihrer
betroffenheit und es da sind auch nicht
sehr wenige wütend dass da aus ihrer
sicht zu wenig gemacht wird sind sie
wollen auch nicht ins privatleben zurück
gedrängt werden
sie wollen keine re tradition ali
sierung deswegen frage ich sie was
wollen sie was wollen sie als
bundesregierung gegen konkret den
rückfall in traditionelle
rollenverteilung tun
ja ich muss ihnen sagen ich bin
zum in diesen tagen und wochen wirklich
sehr noch mal daran erinnert worden dass
wir eigentlich noch gar nicht so lange
ein rechtsanspruch zum beispiel auf dem
kita hand auf einen kita platz haben und
dass das doch eine ganz ganz wichtige
sache und glücklicherweise auch eine
sehr sehr gut angenommene sache ist also
ich werde mich mit allem aller kraft
dafür einsetzen dass wir keine re
tradition ali sierung etwa bekommen
sondern dass der weg der gleichen
chancen für männer und frauen es gibt im
übrigen auch viele väter die sich jetzt
mit dem homeschooling beschäftigt haben
sind nicht nur mütter aber ich stimme
ihnen zu dass wenn man diese summe der
stunden nimmt wahrscheinlich die mit
sehr viel stärkerem maße belastet sind
mit sport das an noch mehr zu tun wir
haben mehr uns vorgenommen auch etwas zu
tun für ein rechtsanspruch für betreuung
im grundschulalter als koalition alle
diese dinge müssen fortgesetzt werden
und wir sind auch sehr froh dass jetzt
die notbetreuung ja glücklicherweise
sich wieder in die öffnung der kitas
auch fortentwickeln kann und das
hoffentlich dann diese ausübung von
berufstätigkeit für männer und frauen
wieder besser möglich mit nachfragen
vergütet werden das natürlich sehr genau
beobachten
vielen dank ich habe eine nachfrage
konkret für den politischen raum sind
sie mit dem anteil der frauen in den
politischen entscheidungsprozess ionen
die aktuell mit der bekämpfung der
korona krise befasst sind zufrieden
glauben sie dass so die perspektive von
frauen ausreichend berücksichtigt wird
insbesondere vor dem hintergrund dass
sie die ministerin für frauen und
familie nicht dass ständiges mitglied in
der korona kabinett berufen haben frage
ich das jetzt auch ganz direkt an sie
als bundeskanzlerin strenge nun haben
wir 200 kabinette einen kern kabinett
das montags takt und ein erweitertes
dass die familienministerin dabei dass
in sitzungswochen nicht mehr donnerstag
tagen wird weil wir festgestellt haben
dass wir dann in konflikt mit dem
bundestag kommen und der natürlich
vorrang hat für die bundesregierung also
die
bundesfamilienministerin ist dort drin
und insofern sehe ich da überhaupt
keinen nachholbedarf zumal franziska
gefallen bei uns wirklich und auch bei
mir gehör und sie hat auch eine gute
stimme die sich deutlich macht was sie
will also da sehe ich keinen
nachholbedarf
jetzt war bin ich zufrieden ich muss
ihnen sagen was mich freue dass es
ziemlich viele professoren und
wissenschaftlerinnen im biologischen
bereich im bereich des öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienstes in den ethischen
bereichen gibt ich habe da viele jetzt
kennengelernt auch im zusammenhang mit
beratung was die politischen
entscheidungsträger anbelangt ändert
sich natürlich jetzt nicht ad hoc etwas
durch die frage aber gerade im
gesundheitsbereich haben wir tendenziell
mehr frauen als in gremien als im
wirtschaftsbereich ob das nun wieder für
die gleichberechtigung schon spricht das
weiß man auch nicht aber ich habe im
augenblick mit sehr viel frauen zu tun
die auch beraten die zum teil selber
beruf und familie zusammenbringen müssen
und deshalb auch aus eigenem erleben
sprechen danke norbert lein durch cfd
stellt die nächste folge der vielen dank
herr präsident frau kanzlerin am 5 ein
urteilte das bundesverfassungsgericht
oberste wächter unseres grundgesetzes
dass gewisse beschlüsse der ezb zum kauf
von staatsanleihen kompetenzwidrig sein
und damit wie sie es auch gewisse
urteile des bgh als nicht
nachvollziehbar und willkürlich zurück
eu kommissionspräsidenten von der leyen
reagierte prompt sagte dass sie schritte
gegen deutschland prüft bis hin zum
vertragsverletzungsverfahren ihren
äußerungen zufolge sei der kern der
europäischen souveränität berührt was
auch immer das sei die urteile des
europäischen gerichtshofs für alle
nationalen gerichte seien bindend und
das eu recht hat für sie auch vorrang
vor nationalem recht offenbar auch vor
dem grundgesetz mit seiner
ewigkeitsgarantie meine frage an sie ist
nun wie werden sie als bundeskanzlerin
unser bundesverfassungsgericht gegenüber
offenbar übergriffigen eu institutionen
vertreten was sagen sie zu den kritikern
dieser entscheidung die den
bundesverfassungsgericht eine spaltung
europas vorwerfen spalte das
bundesverfassungsgericht europa spaltet
unser grundgesetz europa also erstmal
haben wir die entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts zu
respektieren und das tue ich
selbstverständlich auch zweitens ist es
habe ich ein interesse daran dass die
möglichkeiten die das
bundesverfassungsgericht eröffnet hat
auch genutzt werden um den konflikt
kleiner zu machen und nicht größer zu
machen
drittens gibt es in weiten teilen ist
bagger ausdrücklichen weiten teilen eine
eindeutigen vorrang des europarechts vor
dem nationalen recht das ist durch
rechtsprechung des europäischen
gerichtshofs auch deutlich gemacht
worden aber immer da wo die frage ist
welche kompetenz genau hat er nun einen
krieg statt an die europäische ebene
gegeben da kann es natürlich an den
rändern dieser auslegung der kompetenz
auch zu fragestellungen kommen die
manifestieren sich jetzt in diesem
urteil
ich glaube wir müssen mit einem klaren
politischen kompass an die bearbeitung
dieser aufgaben jetzt gehen und diese
compass heißt für mich ich möchte einen
starken gemeinsam eine starke gemeinsame
währung ein euro und in diesem sinne
werden wir jetzt auch vorgehen und dass
die kommissionspräsidentin den ihrer
verantwortlichkeit auch fragen stellt
das ist normal das
vertragsverletzungsverfahren ist ja
nicht dass man einfach ein
vertragsverletzungsverfahren macht
sondern dass er der erste schritt ist
ein letter of intent also es werden
fragen gestellt an die bundesregierung
diese bundesregierung fragen wird die
bundesregierung nach besten wissen und
gewissen und in voller verantwortung für
die bundesrepublik deutschland in
europäischer gesinnung beantworten das
wünsche ich ihnen sehr nun ist es ja so
dass das urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichts auch
versäumnisse der bundesregierung
festgestellt hat es geht ja konkret
darum dass die verhältnismäßigkeit der
entsprechenden staatsanleihen käufe
nicht ausreichend definiert war und dort
wurde im endeffekt auch der
bundesregierung und dem bundestag muss
man dazu sagen vorgeworfen hier nicht
diese verhältnismäßigkeitsprüfung
eingefordert zu haben wo liegt da ihre
persönliche politische auch
verantwortung als bundeskanzlerin und
zum 2 wir werden sie nun konkret sie
haben gerade von einem politischen
kompass gesprochen dieses urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichtes umsetzen
auch im hinblick auf den zukünftigen
potenziellen staatsanleihen
ja meine aufgabe in diesem bereich liegt
daran das urteil zu respektieren und das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat über
bundestag und bundesregierung genau das
gesagt was gesagt haben das müssen wir
zur kenntnis nehmen
und wie gesagt wir werden in klarer
europäischer ausrichtung dann unseren
beitrag dazu leisten und wie die genau
aussieht werden wir sie zu gegebenen
zeitpunkt sicherlich informieren aber
unser beitrag dazu leisten dass ein
starker euro weiter bestehen kann
christian petri spd steht die nächste
frage was vielen dank herr präsident
sehr geehrte frau bundeskanzlerin es
geht auch ums urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichts zur
staatsleihen anleihenaufkaufprogramm psp
danach liegt keine unzulässige
staatsfinanzierung vor dass ein
positives ergebnis dieses urteils
gleichwohl ist der nachweis der
verhältnismäßigkeit kritisiert worden
deshalb sehen wir es als problematisch
an das urteil im hinblick auf den
europäischen rechtsraum zum einen ist
die zuständigkeit das bgh hier sage ich
mal hinterfragt zum anderen sind wir als
bundestagung bundesregierung
aufgefordert auf die ezb hinzuwirken
diese verhältnismäßigkeit darzulegen
europarechtlich ist aber eine
einflussnahme wie sie wissen nicht
vorgesehen
auch auf wunsch deutschlands und die
unabhängigkeit der zentralbanken auch
der bundesbank der nationalen banken zu
sichern
deshalb die frage wie kommen wir aus
dieser quadratur heraus ich würde sie
gerne fragen wie bewerten sie dieses
urteil in diesem lichte was werden sie
tun dass es zum teil eben von ihm
beantwortet worden
eine frage würden sie eine vertiefung
der wirtschafts und finanzunion
befürworten das heißt auch eine
institutionelle weiterentwicklung und
nicht der ezb diese aufgabenstellung
dauerhaft zu übertragen sondern gewisse
blockade möglichkeiten im europäischen
rat zu überwinden
ja also wie gesagt ich es geht ja nicht
um meine meinung zu dem urteil sondern
es geht darum dass sich das urteil zu
respektieren habe das gebietet dass die
rolle des bundesverfassungsgerichts und
seiner urteile und es geht jetzt darum
dass wir verantwortungsvoll handeln und
so klug handeln das sozusagen die dinge
sich der euro weiter bestehen kann und
soll und wird und dass auch die
bundesbank an den aktivitäten der ezb
teilnehmen kann denn wir sind ja
mitglied der europäischen union und des
euroraums und das wird in der tat uns
eher anspornen müssen im bereich der
wirtschaftspolitik mehr zu tun um die
integration voranzubringen und wir
werden uns sicherlich sehr spezifisch
mit dieser frage schon im zusammenhang
mit dem sogenannten recovery fand
beschäftigen denn da geht es um
europäische solidarität und je stärker
die europäische antwort in dem
zusammenhang ist umso sicherer kann auch
die ezb ihre arbeit machen da gibt es
durchaus eine interconnects ion und
alles was wir in dem bereich der
politischen entscheidung machen ist dann
ja auch wird dann ja auch gebilligt
durch den deutschen bundestag was dem
bundesverfassungsgericht immer sehr
wichtig ist dass es eine bestimmte
entscheidung des deutschen parlaments
der gewählten abgeordneten ist und genau
auf diesen weg müssen wir stärker gehen
ich meine wir dürfen nie vergessen dass
sagte lohr vor einführung des euro
gesagt hat es bedarf auch einer
politischen union allein einer
währungsunion wird nicht reichen
wir sind da einige schritte
vorangekommen aber wir sind nicht
ausreichend vorangekommen und das ist
vollkommen evident das heißt es wird
eher mehr integration geben müssen als
weniger ohne dass ich heute hier schon
spezifisch etwas sagen kann ich habe in
einer regierungserklärung am 23 april
ihr gesagt es kann nicht sein dass wir
sagen vertragsveränderungen sind tabu
sondern dass es vertragsänderungen sind
auch immer bewusster akt der
nationalstaaten
aber sie dauern und wir müssen jetzt
natürlich auch möglichkeiten finden in
der pandemie sehr schnell zu ahnden
dann bilden sie ein nachfrage still also
geht's ja eine nachfrage und herzlichen
dank auch für diese wirklich gute
antwort aus meiner sicht die bietet
europäische perspektive
auch dass wir als bundestag gefordert
sind öfter stellungnahmen zu begleichen
vielleicht wird dann auch nachfrage zum
einen hat der bundesfinanzminister ein
bemerkenswertes schluss auf europäischer
ebene herbeigeführt den ich fast
historischen ende das mal einigung über
die weiterentwicklung und die 500
milliarden hilfe auch über den esm
kredit dass man dies geschafft hat das
ist eine große leistung finde ich und
ich glaube dass wir darauf aufbauen auch
das recovery program betrachten können
und meine frage meine nachfrage bezieht
sich auf die danach kommen die
perspektive des mehrjährigen
finanzrahmens können sie sich vorstellen
auch über institutionellen eigene
weiterentwicklung auch hier in der frage
der eigenen mitteln nämlich des
anleihenkaufs auch eine
gestaltungsmöglichkeit zu finden wer
soll anleihen aufkaufen
wobei die eu ach so
das heute nicht so ganz aber
wahrscheinlich dr ich bin für die meine
stellung das meinte ich genau eine
anleihe begeben
ja dass die anleihe begibt so es gab
ich möchte mich jetzt zu den spezifika
nicht äußern ich habe sehr viel
sympathie dafür dass wir eine lösung im
recovery fand finden die nicht
abgespalten von dem normalen budget des
europäischen der dass also der
europäischen union ist das heißt wir
brauchen einfach mehr finanzmittel in
den ersten jahren um die folgen der
pandemie zu bekämpfen aber wir sollten
nicht sagen das machen wir jetzt mal und
wie es in den nächsten sieben jahren
sonst weitergeht sagen denn ich das
hängt für mich in einem ganz steht in
einem engen zusammenhang und die
varianten die wir diskutieren da bin ich
noch nicht so weit dass ich da jetzt
öffentlich darüber spreche aber wir
müssen handeln und wir müssen der
außergewöhnlichen lage in der wir sind
auch rechnung tragen dann gesellte
kollege albrecht glaser möchte dazu eine
frage stellen die ezb hat seit 2005 10
und 2,8 millionen staatsanleihen von zum
teil hoch verschuldeten euro staaten
aufgekauft es ist völlig unvorhersehbar
wann und in welcher höhe diese an
einigen markt zurückgeführt werden
und es ist ebenfalls unvorhersehbar
welche ausfallrisiken auch mit wirkung
für deutschland mit diesem anleihen
erwerb verbunden ist diese transaktion
soll angeblich der finanzstabilität
dienen es könnte aber auch sein dass es
eine eu rechtlich verboten
staatsreligion ist
haben sie daher verständnis für die
sicht des bundesverfassungsgerichts das
die verhältnismäßigkeit des handelns der
ezb infrage zu stellen ist
bundesverfassungsgericht sich ja gerade
mit der frage der staatsfinanzierung
auseinandergesetzt und hat seine meinung
dazu ja auch gesagt und gesagt dieser
sachverhalt das nicht gegeben und es
weiter ist ich habe ihn ja schon gesagt
dass ich
das urteil des bundesverfassungsgerichts
respektiere ihre frage gibt mir aber
gelegenheit zu einer anderen betrachtung
noch einmal der frage des euro der euro
ist eine währung die auch global gewicht
haben soll und er mehr gewicht bekommen
soll als sie es heute hat denn weniger
gewicht und damit ist der euro auch eine
währung die natürlich in relation zu dem
handeln anderen also die europäische
zentralbank ist eine zentralbank die im
vergleich auch zu anderen zentralbanken
der welt zur fed zu der bank of england
zu den japanischen banken zur
chinesischen banken steht und die sich
natürlich in diesem konzert auch
bewähren muss sie hat also auf der einen
seite ihre vertraglichen grundlagen und
die situation dass wir eine europäische
union ein konstrukt sui generis wie man
sagen würde sind also kein staat
selbstverständlich aber auf der anderen
seite eine gemeinsame währung haben die
sich bewähren soll ich habe ein
interesse das meinte ich auch mit dem
starken euro 1 euro der sich der
mitspielen kann im der einen anleihe
fähiger eine andere währung auch ist wo
man seine anlagen auch sich sicher wähnt
und deshalb ist das schon auch ein
spannungsfeld in globalen globaler
akteur zu sein und gleichzeitig im
europäischen konzert zu arbeiten dann
wäre die nächste frage und
voraussichtlich die letzte frage in
dieser regierungsbefragung stellte
kollege hartmut mpg fdp ja vielen dank
herr präsident frau bundeskanzlerin ich
freue mich dass sie in ihrer letzten
podcast corona und kultur betont haben
dass kulturelle veranstaltung sehr
wichtig sind für unser leben und von
allergrößter wichtigkeit sind digitale
alternative formate sind schnell und mit
großer kreativität entwickelt worden
aber können nicht das live-erlebnis
ersetzen das wissen wir beide
da ist eine andere emotionen drin sie
haben jetzt vor kurzem bundesländer
aufgefordert eröffnet konzepte zu
entwickeln
wie theater opernhäuser und her und
konzerthäuser auch kinos wieder
aufmachen können
meine frage an sie warum ist das jetzt
ist erfolg dass er es jetzt wann können
wir mit ergebnissen rechnen und werden
die ergebnisse mit den ländern
abgestimmt also die aufforderung geht ja
vor allen dingen an die länder zusammen
mit der staatsministerin für kultur aber
zuständig sind ja die länder ich habe
jetzt im augenblick den heutigen
überblick nicht ob es länder schon gibt
die schon konzerte in aussicht gestellt
haben ab einem bestimmten zeitpunkt aber
ich glaube nach den anforderungen an
abstand und ähnliches wird man
sicherlich den konzertsaal nicht so voll
machen können wie man es bis jetzt
gemacht hat mit zuschauern
wir haben das europa konzert der
philharmoniker zum beispiel gehabt hier
in berlin und auch daniel barenboim hat
musiziert das heißt auch für die musik
musiker gelten dann die aufgaben das
irgendwie die bläser woanders stehen
weit entfernt von den geigen aber dass
da kann man ja kreativ sein und ich
glaube jedes live erlebnis ist wirklich
dann auch wünschenswert ich denke dass
das sehr schnell jetzt auch in gang
kommen wird wie sein kollege bitte gerne
die kinobetreiber benötigen nach meiner
formation circa vier wochen vorlaufzeit
um ihre kilos wieder aufmachen zu können
und einen einheitlichen
wiedereröffnungstermin weil nationale
oder internationale quali film debüts
brauchen sozusagen die bundesweite
aufmerksamkeit wird die bundesregierung
zusammen mit den ländern einen
gemeinheit gemeinsamen termin sozusagen
vereinbaren und wann es mit einer
ankündigung zu rechnen also an mir wird
sich liegen dass ein einheitlicher
termin gefunden wird
der kollege erhard grund und boden die
grünen möchten noch eine frage stellen
herr präsident frau bundeskanzlerin ihre
videobotschaft vom wochenende ist
tatsächlich viel beachtet worden
in der kunst und kulturszene sie haben
damit ein wichtiges signal gegeben nicht
zuletzt weil natürlich neben der
gesellschaftlichen relevanz auch die
wirtschaftliche relevanz von kultur und
kreativwirtschaft nicht zu
vernachlässigen ist was haben sie denn
für konkrete vorstellungen von
unterstützungsmaßnahmen dieses jahr im
podcast auch angekündigt haben
maßnahmen die vielleicht speziell auf
die arbeitsrealität viele kreativen
abgestimmt sind die freiberuflich
unterwegs sind also die wir haben schon
einige belange von künstlerinnen und
künstlern mitgedacht bei den programmen
die wir jetzt hat ein solo
selbstständige grundsicherung die
staatsministerin für kultur hat
spezielle programme auch noch mal
aufgelegt aber wir haben ja auch vor
noch einmal einen schritt zu gehen auch
insgesamt zur belebung der wirtschaft
und in dem zusammenhang wird auch die
kultur natürlich eine wichtige rolle
spielen denn es ist sie sagten schon
kreativ wirtschaft von großer bedeutung
daran wird gearbeitet und zum gegebenen
zeitpunkt können wir ihnen das dann auch
vorstellen
da haben wir sehen wir am schluss der
regierungsbefragung ich danke dir dafür
bundeskanzlerin
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und rose aus den tagesordnungspunkt 2
fragestunde
ja